- [Instructor] We are
told that the first five
ionization energies for
a third period element
are shown below.
What is the identity of the element?
So pause this video
and see if you can
figure it out on your own
and it'll probably be handy
to have a periodic table of elements.
So before I even look at a
periodic table of elements,
let's make sure we
understand what this table
is telling us.
This is telling us that if
we start with a neutral atom
of this mystery element,
it would take 578 kilojoules per mole
to remove that first electron
to turn that atom into an ion
with a plus one positive charge.
And then, it would take another
1,817 kilojoules per mole
to remove a second electron.
So to make that ion even more positive.
And then after that it would take another
2,745 kilajoules per mole to
remove the third electron.
And then to remove the fourth electron,
it takes a way larger amount of energy.
It takes 11,578 kilojoules per mole.
And then the fifth
electron takes even more,
14,842 kilojoules per mole.
And so, for the first, second, and third
you do have an increase
in ionization energy,
but when you go to the
fourth the energy required
to remove those is way higher.
So to me, these look like you're
removing valence electrons
and these look like you're
removing core electrons.
So one way to think about it is
let's look on our
periodic table of elements
and look for a third period element
that has three valence electrons.
So we have our periodic table of elements.
We want a third period element,
so it's gonna be in this third row
and which of these has
three valence electrons?
Well, sodium has one valence electron,
magnesium has two valence electrons,
aluminum has three valence electrons.
So one way to think about it is
that first electron, it's a
reasonable ionization energy.
Then the second one, a little higher.
Then the third, a little
bit higher than after that,
but then the fourth, you're
starting to go into the core.
You're going to have to take an electron
out of that full second energy shell,
which takes a lot of energy.
And so this is pretty clearly aluminum
that is being described.